[Music]
I'm announcing that this year will be my
last one as a member of the house to be
clear I am NOT resigning
I intend to fool my serve term as I was
elected to do but I will be retiring in
January you all know that I did not seek
this job I took it reluctantly but I
have given this job everything that I
have and I have no regrets whatsoever
for having accepted this responsibility
the truth is it's easy for it to take
over everything in your life now I just
don't want to be one of those people
looking back in my life thinking I spend
more time with my kids when I know if I
spend another term they will only know
me as a weekend father Speaker Paul Ryan
saying he will not seek re-election the
president tweeting out soon after that
announcement speaker Paul Ryan is a
truly good man and while he would not
not be seeking re-election he will leave
a legacy of achievement that nobody can
question we are with you Paul the
president is actually with Paul Ryan
currently he's having dinner at the
White House along with Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell Kevin McCarthy
and Senator John Cornyn as far as
possible replacements when the speaker
does step down you've got Kevin McCarthy
and Steve Scalise who are kind of
jockeying now for position possibly to
be the next speaker or if Republicans
lose the next minority leader let's
bring in our panel
biron new york chief political
correspondent of the Washington Examiner
Abie Stoddard associate editor at
RealClearPolitics and host of No Labels
radio on Sirius XM and Eli Lake
columnist for Bloomberg view maybe you
know a lot of people were surprised by
today the announcement but maybe not
surprised that he was going to make this
move eventually I think a lot of
Republicans we didn't expect him to be
speaker again I think a lot of
Republicans assumed that Paul Ryan was
going to run for his seat wake up the
morning after election day count the
losses and and and quit and that would
be the cheap thing to do and it's just
not like Paul Ryan and he couldn't
stomach doing that his district really
comes first the the kid thing is real I
mean actually wanting to be with his
children who have never known him living
at home full-time Israel
but that said I cannot his fealty to
what was the Republican Party really
cannot be overstated and he really wants
to put everything into an effort to
mitigate the losses to the House
Republican majority this fall he will
not be untethered and he will not be
liberated he will not be criticizing the
president he will do everything he can
into the last hour to try to make sure
they hold the house and keep the losses
to a minimum and Byron it is as of
tonight seeming like it is more of an
uphill battle to do that to hold on to
the house you have 26 retirements 13
running for other office three seats are
vacant so now you're at 41 Republicans
including now the speaker not running
for re-election and the Democrats need
to pick up 25 so it's getting tougher
this is not the sign of a party that's
working well or working smoothly and
even if he put the president's troubles
aside and his relatively low approval
ratings just the historical trends are
terrible for Republicans bill clinton
lost 54 seats in his first midterm
Barack Obama lost 63 seats in his first
midterm it didn't happen to george w
bush because of september 11th this is
not looking good for Republicans now and
the other thing is in this course of
less than three years two Republican
speaker's of the house have just bailed
they just up and quit John Boehner did
it in late 2015 that's how we got Paul
Ryan the speaker in it I think that
speaks to the fact that it is very
difficult to control the faction written
House of Representatives GOP caucus
you've got the freedom caucus you've got
the Tuesday group you've got a bunch of
people you don't have a huge majority
and it's tough to get 218 votes out of
them yeah it tough to herd the cats
alive well I think that you look at the
election of Trump and then to this date
and you're seeing that's the arc of the
transformation of the Republican Party
Paul Ryan is an emblem of
the a Republican Party that was against
deficits was for lower taxes was
certainly there's always a popular
appeal but it's not the same kind of
populist as Trump and now the GOP is
really Trump's party and that is I think
a significant thing when we sort of take
a step back and widen the aperture all
right let's listen to the speaker and
the majority and minority leader on
upcoming months what could come I want
to be clear I'm not done yet
I intend to run through the tape to
finish the year if he's willing to reach
across the aisle he'll find Democrats
willing and eager to work with him I'd
say to Speaker Ryan let's work together
I look forward to collaborating closely
these next months to implement more of
the inclusive pro-growth pro-poor Genda
the American people are counting on us
to keep advancing I mean they put it in
the speeches a B but let's be real what
what is going to happen between now and
November legislatively on Capitol Hill
yeah nothing and and they know that
again I want to return to my first point
he's not going to do anything in his
final months that would potentially
everything will be seen through the
prism of what will depress Republican
turnout in the midterms and that is a
real serrated to distance himself from
Trump as his instinct has been I
actually don't think so because he's
gonna do everything he can to try to
help the Republicans hold on to the
house as for some bipartisan immigration
legislation that he once you know would
have championed I also think that is
going to be seen through the prism of
what will depress Republican turnout in
the midterms they know they're talking
about a rescission package I mean give
me a break to take back to spending that
was just the Democratic spending in the
last omnibus that Trump threatened to
veto in the last hour I don't see that
happening either here's an interesting
poll though Quinnipiac had a poll out
today that maybe tells a different story
than what we're seeing with these
Republican retirements and that is who
deserves credit for the state of the
economy which by all accounts is is
doing pretty well
president Trump gets 55% of women there
you see 49% 46% of Democrats
President Trump gets should the credit
for the state of the economy if by the
time you get to November Byron and the
state of the economy is still cooking
could this you know potential wave of
Democratic wins in the house maybe not
materialized as many people think well
the the only reason to be really
cautious and modest about talking about
this blue wave that's maybe coming in
November is what happened in 2016 I mean
the fact that Donald Trump won the White
House on a day in which his personal
disapproval rating was 60% so if in fact
things don't operate the way they used
to do perhaps that's a real possibility
but the numbers I was talking about the
historical numbers the losses of in
president's first midterms
they really are real and barring some
big event that we don't know about yet
it seems hard to imagine that they
wouldn't happen again and last word on
the the jockeying for position is it
Kevin McCarthy's to kind of position or
Scalise in the in the game here do you
think I think it depends on the
perception at this point about how bad
that loss is going to be in the midterms
and I think that remember Kevin McCarthy
had a chance to run and he declined to
do it the first time around which paved
the way for Ryan and I wouldn't mention
that at this point even though he has
that inside track Scalise probably has
you know the crowd behind her the wind
in his back so to speak by that they
don't know what this election of this
leadership election is going to look
like until they wake up the day after
the election and people start doing a
blame game blame Trump blame the tariffs
blame this blame that they have no idea
and so they're gonna run that race
privately in the months to come but it's
gonna be a different race after November
yeah and we'll be cautious here because
there's a long way to go before November